[Music]
iceland is the world's most isolated
country we're talking about an island in
the middle of the atlantic ocean that is
populated by just a little over 350 000
inhabitants in other words any new york
neighborhood has more people in it the
closest capital city to iceland is oslo
in norway and it is over 1
500 miles that's 2 500 kilometers away
however iceland is one of the richest
countries
in the world and it could become an
international capital of a very modern
industry
cryptocurrencies so could iceland become
the hong kong of cryptocurrencies
iceland a paradise for cryptocurrency
miners info bay so how is it possible
that such a remote country can be so
important for cryptocurrencies in this
video we're going to tell you
[Music]
iceland is one of the most unusual
countries in the world a place where
more than half of the inhabitants
believe in the existence of elves at the
same time is one of the most advanced
and modern economies
on the planet no matter which metric you
look at iceland is one of those
countries that is always at the top of
the rankings icelanders are richer than
americans or dens they are also the
eighth most equal country in the world
in terms of income and they are the
undisputed leaders in renewable energy
basically they are the only country on
earth that can boast that 100 of its
energy
is completely green and i know what many
of you are thinking iceland but isn't
that the country that suffered the most
from the great financial crisis of 2008
exactly when we think of iceland we
think of a country that declared
bankruptcy after the financial crisis
however in just
13 years they have recovered everything
that they lost so how did they do it
we'll deal with this topic in another
video but we can sum it up in three
words tourism
natural resources and cryptocurrencies
check this out
how iceland became the bitcoin miners
paradise the guardian 13th of february
2018.
it is almost impossible to make an exact
calculation of how much bitcoin or how
many cryptocurrencies are mined in
iceland
but it is estimated that this industry
accounts for almost one percent of the
country's entire gdp by some estimates
iceland mines eight percent of all
bitcoin in use today i repeat these are
estimates because no one has exact
information what we can say is that
iceland is becoming increasingly
important within the crypto world
and has a number of advantages that
could make it the hong kong of crypto
the question is to what extent is it
good for an entire country to depend on
bitcoin what environmental impact could
bitcoin have in iceland what are the
advantages that bitcoin miners in
iceland
have today we're going to answer all
these questions but first let's look at
some history
a very hot market for the entire planet
[Music]
i'm sure many of you have heard that
bitcoin miners generate a lot of co2
emissions right and some of you may be
wondering
why what does bitcoin have to do with
pollution and what the heck is a bitcoin
miner some of you may already know but
others will probably not so let's be
clear before we go on here's a breakdown
let's imagine that i have
100 euros which i most certainly don't
but let's just imagine and then i want
to send it to a friend someone has to be
in charge of verifying that transaction
that's to say to make sure that i have
100 euros less in my bank account and
that they have 100 euros more so
who takes care of authenticating these
transactions well in the current
financial system
banks do however banks don't exist in
the crypto world so who verifies the
transaction this is where the miner
comes in
no no no we're not talking about that
kind of minor actually what we're
talking about
is this you see the main feature of
cryptocurrencies is that all users keep
a copy of the same ledger all the
transactions that have been made
in that cryptocurrency throughout
history are stored in that ledger in
other words
technically any bitcoin user could be a
miner so how do you choose who'll be in
charge of verifying the transaction well
you could say that there is a bit of a
contest the bitcoin system creates a
very complicated equation the so-called
proof of work and the first user to
solve it is the one in charge of
verifying the transaction and what does
that person receive in return
well two things on the one hand the
miner is paid a commission for the
transaction
on the other hand he is paid with newly
created bitcoins as you know the idea
behind bitcoin is that only 21 million
bitcoins will be created so those
bitcoins are created as miners are paid
and that's why they're called miners and
yes i know this is a very simple
explanation and we've left out a lot of
things but this is a basic concept that
you need to understand in order to
continue with our story today so
as you can imagine this equation is not
solved manually that is do not imagine a
very smart girl trying to solve it with
a pen and paper actually we are talking
about problems
solved by computers the more powerful
the computer the faster it can solve it
as you can imagine this has led to a mad
race to see who has the most powerful
the computer to give you an idea
this is what a bitcoin mining center
looks like today what you're looking at
are hundreds of processors and graphic
cards put together under one roof to
create
a supercomputer supercomputers can be up
to 800 times faster than a normal
computer and this is where the
environmental issue comes in because
as you can imagine these super computers
consume a lot
of energy but not only that what happens
if you have hundreds of these processors
working at full capacity 24 hours a day
they get hot and as you know a computer
has to be kept cool so can you imagine
how much all these bitcoin mining
centers spend
on air conditioning in other words if
you want to main bitcoin you better get
out your wallet because the electricity
bill is
not cheap check this graph out
[Music]
that's right according to an estimate at
the university of cambridge
mining bitcoin consumes more energy than
a country like
argentina but wait because that's
actually not the worst thing where are
almost all bitcoin mines located well
many of them are in northern china in
fact it's estimated that up to 75
of the bitcoin in the world is mined in
that country for two main reasons cheap
land
and cheap energy but where does china's
energy come from well
it comes from coal which as i'm sure you
know is the most polluting source of
energy and all of that
explains news stories like this one
bitcoin's environmental
footprint threatens the future of the
currency so now i'm pretty sure you
understand where the problem lies right
well pay attention because there is a
solution and this is where
the icelandic factor comes in
the land of cheap energy
that's right in iceland the marginal
cost of producing electricity
is practically free but not only that
100 of the energy consumed in iceland is
green you don't believe me check out
this piece of news iceland offers unique
conditions in the world to produce
cryptocurrencies due to its geothermal
energy which is very cheap and 100
renewable and now
i know what you're wondering what kind
of black magic is this what is iceland
done to get green and very cheap energy
does this have anything to do with those
elves you mentioned earlier grant but
here comes the big advantage of living
in the middle of the atlantic iceland is
right on the fault line that separates
the eurasian tectonic plate from the
north american tectonic plate that's
right
there's a place in iceland where you can
jump and say now i'm in eurasia and now
i'm in north america all this has a
consequence iceland is a volcanic island
with
enormous geothermal activity iceland is
the country of geysers hot springs and
volcanoes with let's face facts
unpronounceable names all this not only
translates into the perfect place for
tourism but we are also talking about a
natural and renewable energy source that
is
limitless and it doesn't end there
another thing that characterizes iceland
is
the cold the average annual temperature
is around 5 degrees this creates a lot
of problems but
surprise it's a huge advantage if you
want to cool big servers or
large bitcoin centers in other words it
was only a matter of time before we
would find news stories
like this one iceland is a land of
volcanoes geysers
and now also bitcoins for example
genesis mining genesis mining is one of
the most important mining companies in
the world today in 2016 they installed a
cryptocurrency mining plant called
enigma they main bitcoin ethereum and
other cryptos 24 hours a day 365 days a
year but they are not the only ones it
is becoming more and more common to find
new stories like this
minersgarden launches new farm in
iceland for cloud mining of bitcoin and
ethereum
the benefits and profitability of mining
in this country have been discovered by
different companies looking for their
share of the pie
but remember i mentioned the huge demand
for electricity with these miners could
this pose a problem for iceland well
take a look at this
bitcoin energy use in iceland set to
overtake homes
says local firm that's right the energy
used by these companies in iceland is
said to have already exceeded
that used by all households and you may
ask so what's the problem after all
energy in iceland doesn't pollute so i
mean that's great right wouldn't it be
great if all the bitcoin miners just
moved to iceland well let's take a look
at the other side of that coin
now
[Music]
the hong kong of cryptocurrencies
this is not the first time iceland has
had powerful financial industry the last
time they occupied the financial
newspapers they ended up
bankrupt we'll tell you more about the
saga in depth in an upcoming video but
now
the question is how did they get out of
the crisis and the answer is by finding
new economic sectors to bet on the first
and most significant
is tourism check this out
[Music]
to give you an idea in 2014 iceland was
already attracting more than one million
tourists a year this is more than three
times its local population since 2011
tourism accounts for one out of every
two new jobs created in the country
another key sector is fishing and
albuminium mining but
since 2016 there is another even more
promising sector
according to the icelandic blockchain
foundation eight percent of all bitcoins
have been mined there
using geothermal and hydroelectric power
although it is impossible to calculate
how much bitcoin is mined in the world
there are estimates that
eight percent of the bitcoin being mined
right now comes from iceland the
government has welcomed these companies
with open arms and it makes sense that
they should
[Music]
a kpmg report states that in 2016 before
the current boom
really took hold the data center sector
had already contributed close to one
percent to the country's gdp that was in
2016. at the time of making this video
it's likely that it's a hell of a lot
more and i know what many of you are
thinking those of you who are veteran
followers of visualpolitik can probably
already see what the problem is going to
be here and those of you who are not
veteran followers of visualpolitik you
can subscribe to this channel and hit
the little bell button down there so you
don't miss any of our updates many of
you will think that the problem with
bitcoin in iceland is that they are end
up becoming dependent on a single
industry right well the truth is that
they won't for the time being iceland
still has a very diversified economy and
it's hard to imagine that bitcoin is
going to change that think about it most
bitcoin mining companies employ
hardly anyone in other words they
generate a lot of money for the country
but most of the people work in other
sectors so where's the problem well
check this out
here you can see iceland's energy
consumption since 2009 it started to
increase
like crazy but why in theory the first
rise is explained by aluminium mining
aluminium was one of the first
industries that helped this country out
of the crisis and that industry consumes
a lot of energy however from 2016
onwards energy consumption starts to
rise yet again
because it is around this time that
bitcoin miners begin to settle in the
country that is with the arrival of new
bitcoin startups demand has skyrocketed
and the following
is happening nordic region bitcoin's
green
haven is running out of surplus
electricity business standard
that's right aluminium plus the advent
of bitcoin mining is putting this
country's supply of green energy on the
ropes and you may ask if
cryptocurrencies really increased energy
demand that much
take a look at this graph here you can
see how every year the energy
consumption of servers and data centers
grows by 50
year after year and yes bitcoin miners
are included in the category of data
centers put it another way bitcoin's
energy consumption is about to exceed
iceland's energy production
all this means that sooner or later the
country will have to increase its power
generation and the question is
can they produce even more green energy
and luckily the answer is yes not only
can they get even more out of geothermal
energy iceland is also starting to build
windmills you see until a few years ago
iceland struggled to install wind power
and why you may ask well because there
was no windmills that could withstand
the gales that occur on the island now
there is technology that makes it
possible to build wind farms in iceland
in other words the problem is not
environmental nor is it the lack of
diversification so where you may ask
is the problem grant please tell us put
out our misery
i know it's got something to do with
those elves right just tell us now well
the problem is
what if one day cryptocurrencies stopped
being so profitable think of it this way
in recent years both bitcoin and
ethereum have grown to amazing highs
that has prompted a lot of entrepreneurs
to jump in and set up their own crypto
mining centers now iceland needs to
build more power generators but
what if one day the crypto rush were to
pass what would happen to all that
installed power side note
i know many of you think
cryptocurrencies are here to stay but
let's be honest none of us know what's
going to happen in the future and it is
very reasonable to suppose that even if
bitcoin is still around in 20 years it
will no longer be as profitable as it is
now everyone can have their own opinion
but it is undeniable that it is more
than likely possibility
in that case what would iceland do with
all the investment it has made faced
with this problem there are two possible
solutions the first is for isil to
consider exporting green energies to
other countries
it would be very expensive because they
would have to lay underwater cables
which are not
cheap but it could become a new revenue
stream for the country the second option
is for the state not to pay for any of
the windmills that is that it is the
bitcoin miners themselves who have to
pay their own energy sources this
solution could be very attractive
because it would allow as many bitcoin
miners as needed to be installed however
it could make iceland less profitable
for the crypto
world what's more other nordic countries
like norway could end up being a better
option so now the question is over to
you what do you think iceland should do
do you think it's a good thing for the
icelandic state to gamble on
cryptocurrencies and build wind farms
paid for with public money or would it
be better if those wind farms were
privately owned by
bitcoin miners in other words bitcoin
miners would manage the energy
they use will we see iceland become the
new wall street of crypto do you think
iceland is ready to be the powerhouse of
bitcoin mining will they be able to meet
the energy consumption needs that the
elves are asking for leave me your
answer in the comments below and as
always don't forget that here at
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to the channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video
please like it and i'll see you next
time